ever wonder how food commercials look so
mouth-watering and perfect these food
shoots can cost hundreds of thousands of
dollars all so you'll buy more of these
visual engineers Steve Geralt's shoots
photos and videos for food and product
based commercials in New York City and
around the world
I bring technology and kind of
traditional image making processes
together in what I call visual
engineering one piece of that technology
robots or as they call them motion
controls Steve's long list of clients
include big brands like Hershey's
Budweiser Pepsi and Starbucks of course
making food looks so good comes with a
price a single day TV shoot can cost
between 50,000 to $100,000 and these
food shoots that we create we have a lot
of moving parts basically you'll have
let's say one item that's moving
something else that's splashing and
running into it something else that it's
going to land on we have to use a lot of
different technologies and you know
synchronizing software to basically
allow those things all to happen at the
exact moment we need them to happen
it also takes a symphony of people to
make the products look the best they can
be various stylist engineers and
operators work together to create the
perfect shot my name is Michele Gunn and
I am a food stylist when I get recipes I
read over the recipes I know what I'm
gonna be doing so in the back of my head
I start thinking about like how I'd like
to do it it's it could change once we
get on set with the different props of
what the art director wants could change
but I start trying to create the recipe
in my head because I'm only making it
for pretty much the first time on set I
made these brownies yesterday just so
we're not waiting on me making brownies
and to make them look like I just made
them just warmed up the chocolate with a
heat gun and I'm adding a little bit of
melted chocolate to the cut side so here
we've got our motorized slider which
moving up which is moving a pump there's
gonna have caramel on it that'll be
pumping down on to our brownie so in the
end while this shot of this beautiful
ribbon of caramel kind of draping and
curling on top of the brownie hook
there's a lot of trial and error
every precise moment captured is nailed
down to the millisecond this is the
benefit to using robots human hands are
also used on commercials when timing is
not a crucial factor we put a lot of
effort into these visuals it's really
cool to see your vision gonna come to
life and be spread with the world I
think you have to have a really great
understanding of what is appetizing
everybody speaks the language of food
[Music]